Matt Gibson I'm in bangalore professor
will have work lights and we will have
personalized and our personal lives I
like to think if we can if we can merge
our personal and our work lives so much
the better I was just wondering your
personal interests in jazz whether
they've had any influence on your work
life and if you can tell us about some
of your or favorite jazz musicians
specifically drummers because I might
emerge as directors are my favorite
musicians at what I would say if I had
to select two musicians it will be
Charlie Parker saxophone alto and to use
manca and I fact I love many other
musicians on trumpet Miles Davis check
Baker piano keys Chad too and concerns
at camera because you are drama will
cite Art Blakey for the jars of the 60s
a blacky of the judge messenger with a
fantastic drama and wynne jones 2 and if
i want to look at the modern run off
today i will will select / motion motion
and also the camera off key Charlotte
Jack DeJohnette huh I don't know if you
agree with my choice but ok I am glad to
answer equation with out of physics I
forgot to to a stop to the second part
of the question about the influence
influence no in fact this is to two
different things and actually one are
you working on physics is difficult for
me to listen to music because I cannot
concentrate at the same time on music
and in physics and so this is to
separate the parts of my life I will say
with of course also part of my life in
order in other fields